kurdisch für Frauen Leben Freiheit das
Leitmotiv der Proteste in Iran wo gerade
für Frauen Freiheit illusorisch und
leben permanent gefährdet ist die Bilder
aus iranischen Städten beweisen es
tagtäglich die Empörung in aller Welt
ist riesig andererseits werden die
Despoten von Teheran vom Westen
offensichtlich geschont auf dass sie
ihre schon Blut fließenden Hände
wenigstens von der Atomuhr belassen ein
Dilemma der Kampf der Frauen wankt das
mularisim jetzt in der Phönix Runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
hier im Studio ist Kinder sahibi sie
sind ausgebildete Ärztin
Politikwissenschaftlerin und arbeiten
jetzt als freie Journalistin und sie
haben Familie und Freunde in Iran
alifatollane Schatz ist deutsch
iranischer Politikwissenschaftler sie
sind unter anderem Iran Experte an der
renommierten amerikanischen Universität
von Beirut Nil Schmidt ist
außenpolitischer Sprecher der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion und zugeschaltet
aus dem ARD Studien Istanbul ist meine
Kollegin Katharina Willinger die nicht
nur das ad-studio in Istanbul leitet
sondern auch das ARD Büro in Teheran von
dem aus sie im Moment allerdings gar
nicht tätig sein können Frau
Internet Kommunikation in und aus dem
Iran ist weitgehend blockiert
bringt trotzdem etwas zu ihnen von
Verwandten von Freunden wie es im Moment
in Teheran in den anderen Städten
aussieht hin und wieder und zuverlässig
also man weiß halt nicht wann man
durchkommt wann man jemanden erreicht
und wann nicht und man ist natürlich
auch extrem vorsichtig mit dem was man
sagt man löscht die Nachrichten wieder
und
es ist absolut unzuverlässig und ich
habe jetzt zum Beispiel seit zwei Tagen
einen Freund nicht erreicht und dann
machen wir auch große Sorgen weil er
selber Journalist ist und das sind halt
so Momente wo man dann einfach nur
abwarten kann frau Willinger unabhängige
Journalistin Journalisten Augenzeugen
vor Ort ist immer gut über gerade was
die Berichterstattung von solchen
Konflikten angeht was da vor sich geht
was sind die Ursachen was passiert da im
Moment ist das nicht möglich werden Sie
auch weiterhin von Istanbul aus darüber
berichten müssen wie sieht es da im
Moment aus mit einer Einreise in den
Iran
ja uns bleibt momentan nichts anderes
übrig wie sie es angesprochen haben als
von Istanbul auszuberichten wir haben
momentan keine Einreisegenehmigung das
betrifft nicht nur mich das betrifft
auch die beiden anderen Kollegen die für
den Iran innerhalb der ARD zuständig
sind wir haben Mitarbeiter vor Ort wir
sind gut vernetzt im ganzen Land und
versuchen unser Bestes um das weniger
was gerade überhaupt rausdringen zu
verifizieren und dann berichten zu
können
es war toll an die Stadt diese Proteste
die wir sehen ist ja wie ein erneuter
Anlauf die Dinge im Iran von Grund auf
zu ändern alle bisherigen Versuche sind
ja in Blut ertränkt worden seit 1979
seit der islamischen Revolution wird es
nach ihrer Einschätzung dieses Mal
anders laufen ist das nur eine Hoffnung
also diesmal haben wir es auf jeden Fall
mit seiner Größe größeren
gesellschaftlichen Basis zu tun mit der
größten im Vergleich zu den anderen
Protesten in der iranischen Geschichte
in der Geschichte der Islamischen
Republik wir haben den letzten wenigen
Jahren landesweite Proteste gehabt gegen
das Regime von den unteren Schichten
diesmal sehen wir eine sehr sehr breite
soziale Basis für die Frauen ganz vorne
sind die Jugend aber auch Teile der
Mittel und Unterschicht
Herr Schmidt die Kritik an der
Bundesregierung sie sind nicht der
Vertreter der Bundesregierung in der
Sendung aber sie gehören der Partei des
Bundeskanzlers an und werden
wahrscheinlich seine Politik
unterstützen ja
Regierung wird ja kritisiert über die
sich viel zu sehr zurückhalten mit
Kritik an dieser nahezu entgrenzten
Brutalität der iranischen Machthaber
Hintergrund ist man wolle die
Wiederbelebung des atomabkommens nicht
gefährden hat da stocknüchterne
Realpolitik Vorrang vor Menschenrechten
nein auf gar keinen Fall die Fragen der
Menschenrechte und des nokia-abkommens
haben wir immer voneinander
unterschieden wir waren immer dafür dass
wir ein Abkommen mit dem Iran schließen
damit er nicht Atomwaffen in die Hände
bekommt und trotzdem ist klar dass
Menschenrechtsverletzungen angeprangert
werden auch wenn sie im Iran stattfinden
unabhängig vom Verlauf der Verhandlungen
und sowohl die Außenministerin wie auch
Kanzler Scholz haben sich deutlich zu
Wort gemeldet
es ist weniger eine Frage Abkommens als
eine Frage der tatsächlichen
Einwirkungsmöglichkeiten auf den
autoritäres Regime von außen das sind
unsere Mittel ehrlicherweise begrenzt
das ist ja etwas was uns seit
Jahrzehnten gerade im Falle des Irans
auch zu schaffen macht man gab es ja
heute im Bundestag eine Aktuelle Stunde
sie waren damit dabei gewesen da war ja
der Vorwurf an die Außenministerin an
den Bundeskanzler sie hätten wenig bis
nichts bisher zu den Prozessen gesagt
zum Beispiel bei der UN-Vollversammlung
in den letzten Tagen aber zumindest die
bundesaußenministerin hat sich heute in
dieser aktuellen Stunde deutlich zum Tod
von
nasser armini geäußert der jungen Frau
und dieser Tod war ja auch der Auslöser
dieser Proteste Annalena bärbock
und bei
allem wenn die Polizei wie es scheint
eine Frau zu todeprügelt weil sie aus
Sicht der sittenwärter ihr Kopftuch
nicht richtig trägt dann hat das nichts
aber auch gar nichts mit Religion oder
Kultur zu tun
sagt Annalena bärburg Frau
eigentlich Massa Amini eine junge Frau
aus dem kurdischen Teil des Iran kann
man über das weiß man über sie mehr als
den Namen
also man hat von ihrer Familie ein paar
Sachen gehört die über sie gesprochen
haben die übrigens sich nicht haben
einschüchtern lassen weil das Regime hat
versucht sie dazu zu bringen nicht
öffentlich zu sprechen über sie und die
Familie hat zum Beispiel auch gesagt
weil das Regime hat ja behauptet sie
hätte einen Vorerkrankung am Herzen
gehabt deswegen habe sie einen
Herzstillstand erlitten und da hat auch
die Familie klar gesagt dass es nicht
wahr ist und das ist nicht richtig ist
und schweren Kopfverletzung die Rede
genau man hat auch Bilder gesehen aus
dem Krankenhaus die ganz klar darauf
hingedeutet haben dass sie massive
Gewalteinwirkungen erfahren hat und das
hat auch ganz es ist auch besonders dass
es eben diese Proteste aus Kurdistan
dass sie dort begonnen haben sie an den
Ausspruch Frauen dem Freiheit vertragen
auf Kurdisch gesagt und das ist wirklich
von Kurdistan von ihrer Beerdigung aus
eigentlich über das ganze Land dort ging
es aus und hat es ganz Land erfasst wenn
ich kurz was zu Annalena Bärbel zu was
sie gerade gesagt hat sagen darf
das was sie gesagt hat waren
Allgemeinplätze also das das Frauen in
Freiheit leben können müssen dass
es nichts mit Religion und Kultur zu tun
hat natürlich ist ist alles klar aber
auch heute im Bundestag hat sie nicht
einmal ganz klar dieses Regime
vorurteilt und wir haben auch nicht
gehört was passieren soll jetzt mit
diesem Regime und man hat sehr wohl
Einwirkungsmöglichkeiten bzw es hat
einen Unterschied entweder man kann die
Sache verschlimmern indem man zum
Beispiel nichts tut was die
Bundesregierung gerade macht und
natürlich kann man jetzt nicht das
beeinflussen was das Regime tut und
nicht tut aber man kann die Sache die
Situation schlimmer machen und das ist
das was die Bundesregierung gerade macht
also wir werden dieses Thema noch
ansprechen im Laufe der Sendung sehr
wichtig die Rolle Deutschlands auch dazu
beleuchten die es da weitergeht der
verdollar in die Stadt das Kopftuch hat
sie also nicht richtig getragen ist von
der Sittenpolizei die dort so heißt
verhaftet worden und möglicher oder
mutmaßlich nach einer Misshandlung zu
Tode gekommen
25 das anzieht also das Kopftuch nicht
richtig getragen und eine solche Folge
nämlich mit der Tod der jungen Frau was
welches Sicht auf Moral auf Kultur auf
Religion liegt einem solchen Weltbild im
Iran bei diesen sittenrechtern zugrunde
also zunächst einmal wurde glaube ich
mittlerweile berichtet dass sie zu enge
Hosen getragen hat was aber auch zu den
sehr restriktiven Vorschriften der
Islamischen Republik gehört wir haben
seit der Revolution im Iran eine
geschlechterappartheit mit sehr starker
mit sehr rigiden Vorstellungen islamisch
fundamentalistischen Vorstellung
patriarchalischen Vorstellungen wie
Frauen sich zu verhalten haben wie
Frauen sich zu kleiden haben Frauen
dürfen beispielsweise auch bestimmte
Ämter nicht bekleiden sie dürfen nicht
Richterin werden also das ist schon eine
lange Geschichte und es gab immer wieder
natürlich die moralpolizei die da auch
sehr rigide also bis hin zu Todesfolgen
angewandt hat bei ihren Kontrollen und
das sagt natürlich sehr sehr viel über
die Natur dieses Regimes aus also es
gibt natürlich die Israel und die
amerika-feindschaft die zu den
ideologischen Pfeilern gehört dieses
Regimes aber es gibt auch diese
Geschlechter Pacht halt die auch zu
einem unabdingbaren Pfeiler geworden
welche religiösen Überzeugungen oder
kulturellen Überzeugungen liegen den
zugrunde dass Frauen hier aus dem
öffentlichen Leben weitgehend verbannt
sind das ist ja nicht das einzige
muslimische Land für das so ist ja es
ist eine eindeutig also es ist eine
islamistische politische Elite die ihre
politisch ideologisch kulturellen
Vorstellungen einer Gesellschaft auf
oktoyiert die in ihrer Geschichte sehr
kosmopolitisch war die nicht solche
reaktionären Vorstellungen mehrheitlich
unterstützt und da sieht man ein großes
Gefälle zwischen Staat und Gesellschaft
in Iran was auch wiederum nicht neu ist
wir wollen uns ja und versuchen das zu
verstehen es sind zwei lesbische Frauen
neulich zum Tode verurteilt worden
homosexuelle Beziehungen im Iran sind
mit der mit der Todesstrafe bedroht und
das Todesurteil wurde
erlassen wegen also die Gründung
Verderbtheit auf Erden Nummer wir
versuchen das ja zu verstehen woher
kommen eigentlich diese diese
Moralvorstellungen dass jemand in seinem
privaten Leben in seiner sexuellen
Bestimmung derartig unterdrückt wird
also diese Art von Unterdrückung von
Frauen vor allem die haben wir in allen
fundamentalistischen Ideologien also die
die finden wir alles was
fundamentalistisch was extremistisch ist
arbeitet eigentlich letztendlich immer
da ist das die Unterdrückung von Frauen
besonders ist immer ein zentraler Pfeile
davon und das war auch im Iran so das
eine der ersten Dinge die Rumänien
damals eingeführt hat also die Macht
übernommen hat war eben der
Zwangsverschleierung und eine der ersten
Demonstrationen übrigens im März 79 kurz
nach die Islamische Revolution passiert
ist warne Demonstration von Frauen die
sind durch zu 10.000 durch die Städte
gezogen ohne Schleier und dann kam wie
alle gerade gesagt hat nach und nach die
nächsten immer mehr
Dinge Entrechtung systematisches also
wirklich eine ganz zentrale Pfeile ohne
diese systematische Unterdrückung kann
dieses Regime gar nicht funktionieren
das ist eine Ideologie mit der man ja
auch Anhängerschaft schafft also das ist
wirklich ohne ohne diese Unterdrückung
kann dieses Regime auch gar nicht
funktionieren
häufiger im Iran gewesen haben dort auch
Delegationen hin begleitet wie muss man
sich das vorstellen oder als
ausländischer Politiker dorthin kommt
bekommt man da etwas mit Felder etwas
auf oder versuchen Ihre Gastgeber sie
davon möglichst fern zu halten ja ich
war zu einem Moment da wo es noch nicht
so repressiv war wir hatten ja einen
leichten Hoffnungsschimmer nach dem
Abschluss des
nuklearabkommens mit Iran
auch eine Hoffnung auf Öffnung die sich
dann nicht bewahrheitet hat und
natürlich ist man da mit als
ausländischer gastmitteltegration eng
eingemauert sozusagen aber was mir
aufgefallen ist ist erstmal diese junge
dynamische Bevölkerung die überhaupt gar
nicht ausstrahlt dass sie was gegen den
Westen hätte also ich habe jetzt nicht
irgendwie den Eindruck dass da jeder der
mir begegnet ist an Amerika Hasser ist
oder sowas
es ist auffällig die gut ausgebildete
Frauengeneration die ausgeschlossen ist
von vielen Bereichen des öffentlichen
Lebens aber eigentlich relativ gut
ausgebildet ist mehr Frauen studieren
als Männer wenn ich das richtig sehe
und was mir sehr eindrücklich ist ist
dass im Unterschied zu anderen islamisch
geprägten Ländern im Alltag die Religion
gar nicht so präsent ist und mir auch
berichtet wurde zumindest dass die die
Molas und die ganzen Islam Gelehrten gar
nicht so jedenfalls in den Städten gar
nicht so anerkannt sind sondern dass
irgendwie die Gesellschaft auch
irgendwie durch ist mit dem Regime so
nach dem Motto die haben einmal die
Runde gedreht einer islamischen Republik
und sehen dass das ziemlich im Elend und
sowohl ökonomisch wie politisch ziemlich
gescheitert ist und daraus speist sich
alles Aufbegehren dass die Iranerinnen
und Iran nach 40 Jahren merken das ist
eine totale Sackgasse und und also das
ist für mich sehr eindrücklich weshalb
ich auch immer dafür werbe jetzt nicht
zu sagen es sind alles
anti-westliche Iraner die das sind so
das Regime die die Potentaten die die
Sagen haben haben diese Ideologie diese
beschrieben haben als Machtinstrument
aber die Bevölkerung ist heute nicht
automatisch an die westlich Frau
Willinger wie haben sie das empfunden
oder wie empfinden Sie
reisen in den Iran wie wirkt dieses Land
auf sich es gibt da diese Sittenpolizei
es gibt religionswächter mit einer
enormen macht das klingt für uns in
Deutschland so ein bisschen nach
Blockwart oder Stasi aus unserer eigenen
Vergangenheit wie muss man sich das
Leben im Iran da vorstellen wie werden
da Menschen gefügig gemacht
ja das kommt natürlich ganz darauf an wo
im Iran Sie unterwegs sind der Iran ist
eine riesiges Land es ist ein viel
völkerstaat es gibt die Mehrheit der
Perser es gibt große Minderheiten das
sind türkische Ethnien kurdische Ethnien
es gibt noch weitere kleinere Ethnien
das heißt da wo man unterwegs ist da
unterscheidet sich natürlich das Leben
von dem Leben in der Großstadt also
beispielsweise in der Hauptstadt Teheran
und auch Teheran ist keine homogene
Stadt wenn wir jetzt davon sprechen dass
man im Alltag in der Stadt unterwegs ist
dann reicht es schon wenn Sie in einem
Arbeiterviertel sind oder wenn sie im
Norden von Teheran sind da bietet sich
ein komplett unterschiedliches Stadtbild
da wir ja jetzt vor allen Dingen auch
über das Alltagsleben von Frauen und von
den Kleidervorschriften gesprochen haben
wenn sie im Norden der Stadt der
Hauptstadt unterwegs sind dann denken
sie sind einem ja in einer Stadt wie
Istanbul unterwegs mit dem Unterschied
dass die Frauen eben im Kopftuch tragen
das Kopftuch rutscht bis auf die
Schultern runter
man steht da nicht hinter diesem
Kopftuch man steht nicht hinter der
islamischen Kleidervorschrift sie haben
die Sittenpolizei angesprochen die ist
unterwegs vor allen Dingen in den
Städten die taucht in verschiedenen
Gruppen auf der heißt auf Persisch Gaste
er schaut und vor allen Dingen ihren
Einkaufszentren oder U-Bahn-Stationen
lauert sie sozusagen eine Frauen auf und
nimmt diejenigen mit die aus ihrer Sicht
eben nicht so gekleidet sind wie Sie
sich das vorstellen aber das Leben Nils
Schmidt hat ja gerade schon annähernd
beschrieben das ist dynamisch das ist
gehen westenorientiert die Menschen
lechten eigentlich danach Kontakt mit
dem Ausland zu haben und viele Menschen
im Iran sind unglaublich wütend darüber
dass ich ihr Land seit Jahren immer
immer weiter abschottet
der Iran ist ja im Prinzip ein
klassisches Beispiel für
patriarchalische Strukturen jetzt fällt
auf dass bei den Protesten auch viele
Männer dabei sind ist das auch eine neue
Entwicklung denn Frauen begehren auf sie
wollen ihre Rechte haben das sind ja
auch Männer müssen dann auch Rechte
abgeben soll ja Gleichberechtigung
herrschen wie ist denn das nur junge
Männer oder macht sich da auch in der
Männergesellschaft in der männlichen
Gesellschaft des Iran eine Veränderung
bemerkbar also neu ist es für die die
iranische meiner Forschung kann nicht
die waren immer so dass sie zeigen es
halt jetzt und ich würde auch dieses
dieses sie sind nicht anti-westlich oder
sie gehen Westen orientiert würde ich
gar nicht so sagen weil die sind halt
einfach so wie wir die haben die
gleichen Bedürfnisse wie wir die haben
das gleich Verständnis von Freiheit und
von Sexualität und von all den Dingen
ist das ist einfach sie sehen natürlich
Iran Familien sind sehr oft verstreut
auf der ganzen Welt das ist das hat die
Geschichte mit gebracht und die sehen
natürlich wie ihre Verwandten wäre
Freundinnen im Ausland leben und Sie
wissen dass Sie das Recht haben genauso
zu leben und diese diese
gender-apartheit und diese Unterdrückung
der Frauen die hat natürlich auch
Auswirkungen auf Männer die können
genauso wenig mit ihrer Freundin
zusammenziehen die können genauso wenig
Sexualität leben wie sie das eigentlich
möchten und daran dass die Männer gerade
eben mit den Frauen kämpfen sieht man
dass es dass es sie alle angeht und das
ist aber nichts Neues dass es da ist es
ist nur was Neues dass man sieht und
dass sie es zeigen ist das auch das
urbane Milieu beschränkt diese
Lebenshaltung die gerade beschrieben hat
ich glaube also zumindest haben muss man
feststellen dass Iran ein sehr
überwiegend ein urbanes Land ist und wir
haben also da gibt es gar nicht so die
großen Unterschiede wie man sich
vielleicht
aus
bestimmter europäischer Sicht ausdenken
mag aber ich noch etwas zu Herrn Schmidt
sagen darf
nach dem atomdeal war die Menschenrechte
noch nicht besser Herr Schmidt das war
damals Iran hatte damals schon die
höchste exekutionsrate der Welt
allerdings wollten wollte man das hier
in Europa und in Deutschland nicht
wahrhaben deswegen und der Präsident
damals wurde auch als Reformer verklärt
er war keine Reformer aber auch kein
moderater also da da ist es war die also
die Menschenrechtssituation ist jetzt
nicht erst seit letzter Woche so
dramatisch sondern sie war schon in den
letzten Jahren so dramatisch und da
hätte Europa sicherlich auch etwas
machen können aber dazu kommen bestimmt
später
das ist ja genau das Problem sie haben
gesagt nach dem ersten atombiel 2015 gab
es dieses aufatmen und da war auch 2016
Sigmar Gabriel dort im Iran und das ist
genau das Ding das Aufatmen gab es nicht
nicht für die Menschen da man will hier
in Deutschland das Ruhe im Karton ist
und dass die halt nicht so viel Quatsch
machen und irgendwie befolgen was sie
halt befolgen sollen aber es gibt in
diesem System keine Reformer es gibt
keine moderaten sondern das ist ein
komplettes System der opressionen von
seit Beginn des Bestehens Republik wir
hatten 1988 Massenhinrichtungen wo
Tausende von Menschen auf einmal
exekutiert wurden es gab es gibt in dem
Land nie an aufatmen
Deutschland und auch Europa darüber über
diese Konflikte hinweg sieht man möchte
Entspannung in dieser brisanten prekären
Weltregion haben die sitzen ja alle
praktisch auf Pulverfässern da kann
jederzeit ein gravierender Krieg
ausbrechen ist ja auch schon zum Teil
ausgebrochen sind wir da etwas zu
optimistisch nein sicher nicht wir sind
ja nicht blöd also wir wissen ja schon
wie die Lage meran ist und wir wissen
auch um die Menschenrechtslage seit
Jahrzehnten sondern wir haben eben eine
komplexe Gemengelage dass wir einerseits
die Drohung haben dass die Iran an die
Atombombe kommen und das würde natürlich
die Sicherheitslage die Stabilität im
Nahen Osten völlig verändern das würde
wahrscheinlich dazu führen dass es ein
Rüstungswettlauf auch andere Nachbarn in
der Richtung Atombombe gebe und deshalb
haben wir immer darauf Wert gelegt auch
mit Blick auf die Bedrohung Israel sucht
den Iran dass wir alles dafür tun dass
der Iran nicht zu Atomuhr bekommt und es
gibt keinen der mir bisher erläutern
könnte dass es einen besseren Weg gäbe
als ein Abkommen weil niemand ernsthaft
ein Krieg um die Atomuhr mit miran
führen will und deshalb war der
Hoffnungsschimmer einer der zunächst mal
auf das Thema
Atombombe und mögliche wirtschaftliche
Öffnung
ausgelegt waren mir ist klar dass das
jcpo also dieses atomabkommen an der
Menschenrecht sage gar nichts geändert
hat oder ändern kann
sondern wir wollen dass Atombomben weder
in der Hand eines diktatorischen nach
Möglichkeit auch nicht in der Hand eines
demokratischen Irans sind weil wir
einfach die nicht Weiterverbreitung von
Massenvernichtungswaffen
anstreben das ist der Punkt dass die
Menschenrechtslage
katastrophal ist das ist uns allen
bewusst die Frage ist nur
welche Veränderungen können wir wie von
außen anstoßen und der Hoffnungsschimmer
der Öffnung einer gewissen
wirtschaftlichen Öffnung war ja der das
innerhalb des Irans die
gesellschaftlichen Kräfte stärker werden
die sozusagen eine Zusammenarbeit mit
dem Westen auch ökonomisch unterfüttern
werden es kann man sagen Wandel durch
einen Ernährung funktioniert nie wir
haben auch Beispiele wo es nur begrenzt
funktioniert hat aber das war der
Begriff Hoffnungsschimmer aber für die
Menschenrechtsfragen war das natürlich
erstmal kein hoffnungsschwimmer dass wir
uns eigentlich
es gibt ja dieses westliche framing das
hat jetzt auch Nils Schmidt so ein
bisschen angedeutet dass wir ein sagt
wenn es jetzt zu diesem atomabkommen
kommen sollte dann hat die USA ja schon
angekündigt werden die Sanktionen
weitgehend aufgehoben der Iran wird aus
seiner isolierten Lage befreit diese
dieser pariastat im Westen wird wieder
beseitigt und dann hätte man die
Möglichkeit von außen auf Reformen im
Iran gegenüber den mularegime zu dringen
ist das eine eine framing das sind die
gewisse Logik hat oder ist das
Wunschdenken
ich glaube um dieses Ziel überhaupt
erreichen zu können müsste man erstmal
einen Schritt zurückgehen zunächst muss
man mal festhalten dass die iranische
Führung die islamische Führung dass
jcpoa also das atomabkommen ja seit
Jahren als Druckmittel nutzt um den
Westen um die Verhandlungspartner die
damit am Tisch sitzen zu erpressen das
heißt man weiß ganz genau indem man
immer wieder Zahlen veröffentlicht neues
Uran angereichert auf 90 Prozent
hochgefahren der Westen zittert und hat
Angst vor der Atombombe und das bringt
den Iran in eine sehr starke
Verhandlungsposition am Tisch und führt
dazu dass die
Verhandlungspartner zu denen ja eben
auch Deutschland gehört gerade beim
Thema Menschenrechte ganz wenig in diese
Verhandlungen mit eingebracht haben um
nicht zu sagen gar nichts mit
eingebracht zu haben haben das heißt man
müsste von vornherein wenn man darüber
spricht mit dem Iran ein ab zu schließen
egal in welcher Form das Thema der
Menschenrechte als einen der wichtigsten
Punkte festhalten und nicht erst sagen
dann wenn es soweit ist wenn wir ein
Deal ausgehandelt haben dann schauen wir
mal wie es weitergeht
wir werden mit dem Iran kein
komplettabkommen schließen wo wir alle
Streitkräfte verhandelt wir werden mit
dem Iran kein komplettabkommen schließen
können wo wir alle Streitfragen von den
Menschenrechten der Demokratie bis hin
zur Atombombe und der regionalen Rolle
des Irans aufrollen können das ist das
völlig illusorisch
das völlig illusorisch sondern die
internationale Gemeinschaft hat sich
darauf verständigt dass eine sehr
dringende Bedrohung ein Atom einer
Atombombe des Irans ist und deshalb hat
man sich in den Verhandlungen darauf
konzentriert diese Frage zu lösen dass
die Menschenrecht sage dadurch nicht
verbessert wird das hat niemand
behauptet sondern es gab nur den Ansatz
durch die Verknüpfung aufhebungs
Optionen und Verzicht auf Atomwaffen
dass man eine
innere Entwicklung im Iran vielleicht
anstoßen kann die nach und nach mehr
Freiräume schafft ohne dass es dafür
eine Garantie gibt aber zu glauben man
könnte mit ihm ran ein Abkommen
schließen mach mal was bei dem
Menschenrechten und wir würden dann den
Atomwaffen für sich feststellen das wird
nicht funktionieren
eine Frage stellen sie haben mir vor
Israel erwähnt Israel gesehen das glaube
ich einig weil als allererster Staat
bedroht von der iranischen Atomwaffe wir
haben in it-rahmen steht eine Uhr da
werden die Tage herabgezählt wann der
zionistische Staat vernichtet ist so das
wird da wird eine Uhr runtergezählt
Israel ist komplett gegen dieses
atomabkommen was glauben Sie denn warum
ja da gibt es eine
Meinungsverschiedenheiten mit der
israelischen Regierung vor allem mit der
netanjaro Regierung aktuell
israelischen Militär dieses komplett
anders sehen ja weil eben die die
Regierung in Israel der Meinung ist dass
man sehr hart gegenüber dem Iran
vorgehen muss diese Meinung teilen wir
mit Ausnahme beim atomabkommen wir sehen
keine Möglichkeit jenseits eines
Abkommens den Iran davon abzuhalten die
Atome zu entwickeln darf ich eine Bitte
äußern dass sie vielleicht noch mal zu
dem Thema zum Titel der Sendung der
Kampf der Frauen Bank das monarchim kurz
zurückkehren ich will das nachher auch
noch mal ansprechen im Zusammenhang mit
der Geopolitik des Mittleren Ostens sie
haben selbst gerade gesagt viele junge
Iraner gucken nach Westen die wollen ins
Ausland die wollen Kontakt haben die
Wissen über Internet auch wir sind
anderen Ländern aussieht ein Lebensstil
der ihnen viel näher liegt als das was
die Molasse ihnen verordnen wollen das
ist ja insofern interessant dass die
allermeisten Iranerinnen und Iraner ja
gar kein anderes Regime kennen es ist
eine sehr junges Land vor 43 Jahren fast
44 Jahren war die Revolution da gibt es
nur noch ganz wenige Iraner die diese
Zeit davor erlebt haben und dort und
trotz dieser abschottungsversuche der
eiert tollers diese dieser Blick nach
Westen wie kann man sich das erklären
hat diese Umerziehung oder diese
Gehirnwäsche nicht funktioniert ich
glaube ich glaube das Regime hat einen
grundlegenden Fehler gemacht als sie
angefangen haben die Frauen zu
unterdrücken haben sie es nicht
geschafft sie komplett aus dem Leben
auszuschließen also 60 Prozent der
Iraner Studierenden sind weiblich zum
Beispiel sie arbeiten sie fahren Autos
haben schon symbolisches Ding Autofahren
und das war sozusagen ein Fehler dass
sie das gemacht haben weil natürlich
trotzdem die Frauen
sehr selbstbewusst auch sind sich Wissen
aneignen als Ärztinnen arbeiten als
Rechtsanwalt weltinnen und
wie gesagt wie vorhin gesagt habe
Familien sind auch verstreut man hat
Verwandte man hat Freundinnen anderen
Staaten und was auch ganz wichtig ist
über den Iran zu wissen ist dass es eine
sehr starke Trennung zwischen privat und
öffentlich gibt wir haben das
öffentliche Leben wir kennen wir jetzt
alle im Privaten ist es aber so dass
dort das gelebt wird was sie öffentlich
nicht tun dürfen eine dieser Dinge ist
zum Beispiel westliche Medien
konsumieren sehr viel Iranerinnen haben
illegal Satellitenschüssel auf dem Dach
das Regime macht oft nichts manchmal
räumen sie wieder ein übrigens um sie
selber wieder zu verkaufen und Geld zu
verdienen aber das heißt einfach dass
dass diese Menschen
das Leben sehen wie es sein kann und sie
Lebens ja privat auch oft es gibt ja
illegale Partys es werden es wird
Alkohol gebrannt illegal Drogen genommen
das ist ja alles da was übrigens ins
exzessive geht und auch nicht gut ist
aber auch
die Frage ist ja kann man den sagen vor
toller das
die Iranerin und Iraner die jungen
zumindestens quasi die Leben physisch im
Iran aber gedanklich völlig woanders ist
das was macht das mit einer Gesellschaft
auf Dauer diese Unzufriedenheit die sich
jetzt gerade wieder Luft verschafft auf
sehr explosive Weise aber was macht das
mit einer Gesellschaft zerrüttet dass
eine Gesellschaft die sagt also sie
müssen zwar hier leben aber wollen hier
gar nicht leben ich bin hier sozusagen
nur körperlich ansonsten habe ich damit
nichts zu tun was hier passiert naja
vier Jahrzehnte real existieren der
Islamismus in Iran hat natürlich zu
verschiedenen Effekten geführt all diese
gesellschaftlichen Komponenten die gilt
da gerade aufgezählt hat aber auch die
Realisierung dass man nicht etwas
Besseres verdient hat die Rana sehen ja
auch Bilder wie halt die iranische
Gesellschaft vor der Revolution war dass
es solche sozialen Restriktionen davor
nicht gegeben hat man sieht wie der weiß
wie man überall in der Welt leben darf
aber ich ist doch dennoch obwohl sie
diese Diskussion bisschen aufschieben
wollen aufhören Schmidt reagieren es ist
nicht illusorisch solch eine Politik zu
machen schauen Sie man kann eine
umfassende ihrer an Politik machen und
es wäre längst die Zeit dafür ich habe
in den letzten Jahren auch immer dafür
plädiert das zu machen man kann sowohl
das Atom-Deal mit den Iranern besprechen
als auch die Menschenrechte als auch die
Regionalpolitik es kommt ganz drauf an
was für Druckmittel man einsetzt und
Deutschland hat nicht begrenzte
Möglichkeiten Deutschland ist der
wichtigste Wirtschaftspartner die
islamischen Republik Deutschland hat
ungemein viel politisches und
ökonomisches Kapital was man hätte
benutzen können nach dem 2015er atomdeal
ich habe das immer wieder hier in den in
den deutschen in Deutschland gesagt es
wurde gesagt ja das ist eine naive
Vorstellung zu denken dass man durch
diese durch dieses
wirtschaftswirtschaftliche und
politischer Kapital Kurskorrekturen
erzwingen kann aber wenn man als ich das
bestimmt nicht iranischen Politikern
gegeben habe
haben die gesagt das wäre durchaus
möglich gewesen denn eines darf man
nicht vergessen die Islamische Republik
reagiert auf Druck das zeigt die
Geschichte der letzten vier Jahrzehnte
es ist also eine Chimäre zu
argumentieren dass wir übersorisch
Deutschland Deutschland hatte vor allen
Dingen in den letzten Jahren diese
politischen als der Atom die noch da war
hatte man natürlich viel mehr Spielraum
jetzt ist der Spielraum kleiner richtig
aber Deutschland ist immer noch hat
immer noch über eine Milliarde
wirtschaftsaufkommen mit Iran in Zeiten
von Sanktionen man kann
wirtschaftliche und politische
Beziehungen herunterfahren und das hat
man nicht gemacht die Reaktion von Frau
baerbock und von von Bundeskanzler waren
nicht deutlich wie sie vorher suggeriert
haben das ist eine Eigenwahrnehmung hier
in Berlin aber die gesamte Welt sieht
das wirklich anders auch im Iran ist der
Perzeption der deutschen Rolle nicht gut
schauen Sie sich mal die Kommentare
unter den twittern der deutschen
Botschaft an da wird suggeriert dass die
Zurückhaltung Europas Zurückhaltung
Deutschlands eine Unterstützung der
iranischen des iranischen Regimes ist
gut sie können kurz darauf antworten
dann gehe ich noch mal zurück zu Frau
Willinger weil mich natürlich auch noch
die Situation zumindest teilweise
auseinander sie haben recht man kann
wenn man ein bestimmtes Ziel verfolgt
über Druck im Iran eine
Verhaltensänderung auslösen das war die
Erfolgsgeschichte des nuklearabkommens
man hat Druck ausgeübt mit einem
bestimmten Ziel nicht regime change
nicht umfassende Veränderung der
Menschenrechtslage sondern der Erfolg
war der Iran hat unterschrieben Verzicht
auf Nuklearwaffen mit
Kontrollmechanismen
darf ich darf ich vielleicht zu Ende
reden
und mit harten Kontrollmechanismen
verbunden und das war ein Erfolg durch
einheitliche Sanktionspolitik der
internationalen Gemeinschaft und wer hat
diesen Erfolg zunichte gemacht es war
Trump Trump hat einseitig das Abkommen
aufgekündigt und damit und damit die
leverage des Westens gegenüber dem Iran
machen und damit die Levels des Westens
untergraben um die Themen die Sie zu
Recht haben sprechen als mangelhaft
bearbeitet nämlich die regionale Rolle
um die weiter zu bearbeiten bloß man hat
sich darauf verständigt in der
internationalen Gemeinschaft Schritt für
Schritt vorzugehen hat atomabkommen
regionale Rolle und dann idealerweise
auch Menschen ich sage dadurch dass der
erste Schritt von den USA das wissen sie
doch dass der dass das die USA den
ersten Schritt untergraben haben haben
wir natürlich wie Frau Willinger
beschrieben hat
und das war es war aber das war der
große Erfolg der gemeinsame großer
Erfolg wurde von Trump zerstört ich
räume ein darf ich das vielleicht auch
noch sagen um ihnen entgegenzukommen
weil sie ja zu Recht darauf hinweisen
dass die Obama
den Fehler gemacht hat nach dem Erfolg
des JC Perry nicht weiter die gleiche
politische Dynamik für das Thema
regionale Rolle zu investieren das hat
für die für den Westen nicht nur
gegenüber dem Iran sondern auch in der
Golfregion ein Rückschlag ausgelöst das
ist aus meiner Sicht auch ein Problem
dass man zu schnell den Haken dran
gemacht hat nach dem Abschluss des
atomark nicht nur die Amerikaner sind
Moderator mal hier gerecht werden und
sagen
dass wir die Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer müssen ihre Diskussion auch
Folgen können ich hatte ja gesagt ich
komme auch wenn sie jetzt gesagt haben
wir schieben das Thema auf ich wollte es
nicht aufschieben sondern ich wollte nur
das Thema Iran und was dort passiert
abschließen das mache ich jetzt auch mit
Katharina Willinger Frau Willinger hat
denn im Iran hat das gibt es denn auch
noch Schichten Menschen Gruppierungen
die das Regime unterstützen auf die sich
das Regime stützen kann
also ganz kurz um auch noch diese
Diskussion um das atomabkommen
abzuschließen es ist genau das in der
Sendung passiert was viele Iraner die im
Iran Leben bedauern dass dieses jcpoa
die Bericht Erstattung über den Iran
dominiert und dass das Regime über
dieses jcpe regelmäßig ablenken kann wir
reden jetzt hier momentan vor allen
Dingen das Thema der Sendung es geht um
die aktuellen Proteste wenn Sie mich
fragen ob es Menschen gibt die das
Regime unterstützen dann muss ich Ihnen
sagen ja die gibt es aber sie werden
immer weniger es gibt inoffizielle
Umfragen und Schätzungen dass
mittlerweile nur noch 30 Prozent wenn
überhaupt der Menschen im Iran hinter
dem Regime stehen und das muss man
Aussehen sind oft Menschen die
angestellt sind über die Führung die ihr
Geld zu verdienen also unterstützt
werden ein Großteil der Bevölkerung
steht nicht mehr hinter diesem Regime
und das ist für mich auch die neue
Dimension dieser Proteste dass die
Menschen jetzt auf die Straße gehen und
nicht nur das was sie seit vielen Jahren
schon am Küchentisch zu Hause besprechen
nämlich dass sie hochgradig unzufrieden
sind mit der Führung im Land und mit dem
islamischen System an sich jetzt auch
offen auf der Straße skandieren und das
tatsächlich unter Einsatz ihres Lebens
oder zumindest unter Einsatz ihrer
persönlichen Freiheit jetzt ist es ja so
gewesen dass im Iran praktisch mit der
islamischen Revolution von 1979 das Land
ja auch häufig Sanktionen ausgesetzt war
das ging ja damit los dass die
US-Botschaft gestürmt wurde da wurden
über zwei Jahre Geißeln genommen seit
der Zeit reist dass
Sanktionsregime gegen den Iran nicht ab
die Menschen leben unter diesen
Sanktionen das Land ist wirtschaftlich
zerrüttet was macht das eigentlich mit
dieser Gesellschaft vier Jahrzehnte ich
habe es vorhin schon mal gesagt im
pariastatus zu leben nicht das Land
selbst aber die dortige Führung die die
Armut ist weit verbreitet das Land war
Mal blühen das war eines der reichsten
Länder im Orient gewesen auch übrigens
eine Gesellschaft die sehr stark
westlich ausgeprägt war mit einem sehr
sehr hohen Bildungsniveau für den
Mittleren Osten was macht das mit diesem
Land diese Erfahrung von vier
Jahrzehnten
also die Sanktionen sind aus meiner
Sicht mittlerweile einen nationales
Trauma denn jetzt sind sie ja auch
wieder im Gespräch de facto sieht es so
aus dass die Sanktionen die momentan in
Kraft sind und das sind die massivsten
Sanktionen überhaupt seit bestehende
Islamischen Republik die Treffen in der
Praxis vor allen Dingen den einfachen
Menschen den durchschnittsiraner denn
die Macht Elite die Führung im Land die
schafft es auch weiterhin sich zu
bereichern und eben die Sanktionen zu
umgehen also das sind Sanktionen das
sind Geschäfte die strukturell angelegt
sind wir haben vor eineinhalb Jahren
circa mit einem Unternehmensberater
gedreht in Teheran der Firmen berät
ausländische Firmen die mit dem Iran
Geschäfte machen wollen und natürlich
war meine erste Frage wie ist das denn
möglich de facto sind ja die die
Zahlungsgeschäfte der Zahlungsverkehr
komplett lahmgelegt das ist funktioniert
ganz einfach das funktioniert über
Drittländer und Tochterfirmen in den
Emiraten in der Türkei beispielsweise
und das nutzt die Machtelite natürlich
für sich aber beim normalen Iraner bei
der normalen Iranerin kommt eben nichts
an und das führt dazu wie sie es eben
angesprochen haben dass dieses Land die
Mittelschicht in die Unterschicht
abgerutscht ist dass es eine immer
größere Armut gibt und unter 40 Prozent
Pendant der iraner:innen befinden sich
mittlerweile unterhalb der Armutsgrenze
und die Oberschicht mit immer reicher
deswegen wenn jetzt von Sanktionen die
Rede ist gerade auch im Westen dann muss
man sich glaube ich ganz genau ansehen
welche Sanktionen man erlässt die dann
auch wirklich denjenigen die man treffen
will Schaden und das sind vor allen
Dingen personenbezogenes Sanktionen das
geht um Angehörige oder um Mitglieder
der islamischen Führung die auch in
Europa leben zum Teil Geschäfte haben
aber nicht um die normalen in
Anführungszeichen Wirtschaftssanktionen
die am Ende nur dazu führen dass die BEV
im Iran immer ärmer wird das heißt
die wirtschaftliche Macht die
profitabelsten Unternehmen sind glaube
ich im Besitz der revolutionsgarten also
der mächtigsten und gefährlichsten
Institutionen in diesem Land das Land
ist eine Kleptokratie komplett also
deswegen was Herr Schmidt gerade als
Erfolg nach dem atomabkommen beschrieben
hat alles Geld was frei wird durch
jegliche Abkommen durch die Wirtschaft
des wandert sofort auf der einen Seite
vor allem in die revolutionsgrade weil
die diese gardes eine riesige Wirtschaft
macht inzwischen die auch vom
Schwarzmarkt profitiert und damit wird
auch wird sie Armee aufgerüstet die dann
auch die Region stabilisiert
destabilisiert die eben im Ausland auch
tätig ist und also unter Iraner in wenn
man mit Iraner in spricht dann wird das
Privatvermögen von rauminné dem
Revolutionsführer geschätzt was bei mehr
als 90 Milliarden anscheinend liegt
Dollar die wissen ganz genau dass jedes
Geld in die Taschen mit dieser
Machthaber fließt und deswegen
genauso wie Katharinas gerade gesagt hat
bei den Menschen kommt überhaupt nichts
an weil das absolute also wie sie auch
erklärt hat die Menschen die Geld haben
die können eigentlich leben wie sie
wollen die schicken vor allem auch ihre
Kinder ins Ausland zum Studieren das
bleibt in dieser absoluten Elite und es
hat mit den Iranerinnen und den Menschen
die gerade auch auf der Straße sind
überhaupt nichts zu tun stabile
wirtschaftliche Beziehungen ohne
Sanktionen beurteilen genau wieder diese
Elite in Iran die das Land so fest
quasi mit terroristischen Mitteln im
Griff hat deshalb konzentrieren wir
jetzt in der Debatte die wir auch heute
im Deutschen Bundestag geführt haben auf
personenbezogene Sanktionen die EU hat
seit etwa drei Jahren damals auch von
Heiko Maas eingeführt
menschenrechtsbezogene
Sanktionsmechanismen entwickelt wo man
Personen Listen kann damit
Vermögenswerte eingefroren werden
Einreiseverbote durchgesetzt werden und
es ist höchste Zeit dass man das jetzt
auch für den Iran an
ich glaube wenn wir über Sanktionen
reden dann ist das etwas was jetzt
wirklich auf der Tagesordnung steht es
gibt die Überlegung dass wir in
Vorbereitung für Strafverfolgung die
Menschenrechtsverbrechen dokumentieren
wir haben in Belarus in Syrien
entsprechend Verfahren entwickelt es
wird höchste Zeit dass man auch sowas
für den Iran etabliert fest etabliert
damit wir wenn wir dann die Chance haben
der der Leute habhaft zu werden die dann
auch wirklich von Gericht stellen kann
also ich glaube dass so wie Frau
widinger als gesagt hat diese Frage
jetzt ganz oben auf der Tagesordnung
steht oder schnell passieren das ist
eine EU-Entscheidung aber Deutschland
wird es sicher unterstelle
ich würde gerne
noch auf ein Aspekt kommen wenn es
tatsächlich jetzt mit diesen Revolten
mit diesem Aufruhr mit diesem Protesten
weitergeht und der Iran möglicherweise
destabilisiert wird das ist eine wie
gesagt gefährliche Region da gibt es
viele Konflikte auf der Welt was
bedeutet das eigentlich dann für das
ganze Umfeld es gibt ja diesen
schiitischen Halbmond vom Iran über
Syrien bis zu dem Ort wo in dem sie auch
Lehren bis zum Libanon also bis beruht
eine Gefahr für Israel ein ständiger
Unruheherd die Isolation in Syrien ist
völlig ungeklärt auch wegen des Irans
und seiner Haltung was würde das
bedeuten wenn jetzt Iran auch
innenpolitisch distabilisiert wird das
ist eine sehr sehr gute Frage war das
glaube ich auch eine Frage ist die
Berlin sehr stark beschäftigt zunächst
einmal muss man feststellen dass Iran
schon seit Jahren destabilisiert ist das
ist keine Stabilität im Lande das was
wir mitbekommen ein totales
internet-blackout und kriegsähnliches
Szenen und Massaker wir haben im
November 2019 auch landesweite Unruhen
gehabt das Internet wurde abgeschaltet
bis hin zu 1500 Leute wurden umgebracht
das bedeutet dass die dass der
gegenwärtige Status Quo keine Stabilität
darbietet das bedeutet wir müssen viele
Mittel- und langfristiger denken wir
machen oftmals in der iran-debatte die
gleichen Fehler wie in der
russland-debatte auch wir müssen
hingehen und verstehen dass Europas
Nachbarregion in einem
Transformationsprozess sich befindet
nicht nur Iran sondern auch die
arabischen Länder in dem was ich sage
dann langfristigen revolutionären
Prozess anstatt hinzugehen business as
usual zu machen müssen wir schauen
müssen wir eine Paradigmenwechsel in der
Außenpolitik einleiten in europäischer
Zusammenarbeit mit Abstimmung der
Amerikaner weil sonst nehmen die Iraner
und die anderen Diktatoren uns nicht
ernst wenn wir das nicht transatlantisch
einbinden und da muss man diesen
Transformationsprozess zugunsten der
Zivilgesellschaften managen und
begleiten das bedeutet ein absoluter
Paradigmenwechsel es gibt auch andere
Sichtweisen innerhalb anderer
europäischer Staaten und das wäre eine
wünschenswerte Reaktion es ist sowohl
innere wie äußere Stabilität nicht nur
notwendig sondern sie bedingen einander
auch wenn ich Sie richtig verstanden
habe ja was wird jetzt aus diesen am
besten in im Iran und vor allem man darf
nichts man darf nicht vergessen falls
der Iran sich transformiert wird sich
das gesamte Gesicht des Namen mit drin
Ostens verändern wir sind gleich am Ende
der Sendung vielleicht noch ganz kurz zu
dir
möchten was wird aus diesen Protesten
werden ich habe ja am Anfang gesagt alle
bisher sind regelrecht im Blut erstickt
worden wird es dieses Mal
besser ausgehen für die Opposition für
die Menschen die ein anderes einen
anderen Iran wollen ich glaube was wir
jetzt sehen ist tatsächlich der Beginn
eines echten Widerstands das hat mir
bisher noch nicht ich fürchte dass
dieses Regime durch dieses wahnsinnige
Gewaltmonopol dass sie haben sie
irgendwann niederschlagen wird durch
Angst durch Einschüchterung und Gewalt
aber man sieht es jetzt schon dass der
Widerstand sich wirklich organisiert wie
sehen Sie das
ja ich stimme Frau sahibi zu das Gewalt
Monopol ist eben so groß der Staat
besitzt wenn wir um Gewalt über Gewalt
sprechen ganz andere Mittel natürlich
als die Zivilbevölkerung aber das
aktuelle Motto am 14 Tag der Proteste
habe ich mir heute sagen lassen von
einigen der Demonstranten mit denen wir
sprechen konnten ist wir machen so lang
weiter bis sie müde sind und man sieht
bereits dass sie müde sind dass die
Sicherheitskräfte teilweise im Gras
liegen und sich ausruhen das tagsüber
keinerlei Präsenz mehr ist unter anderem
der Sittenpolizei aber auch der normalen
Bereitschaftspolizei weil der Staat
gerade so überfordert ist ich sehe es
auch so es ist ein Schritt ein Schritt
eines langen Weges denn die einzige
Möglichkeit dieses Regime über zu
umzustürzen wäre tatsächlich mit Gewalt
und dieses Mittel steht der
Zivilbevölkerung eben nicht zur
Verfügung aber es ist ein Schritt in die
Richtung eines langen demokratischen
Prozesses
ich bedanke mich für die Diskussion bei
Gilda sahibi bei Alisa toller
Nils Schmidt und Katharina Willinger
zugeschaltet aus Istanbul zu diesem
Thema Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe
Zuschauer die nächste Phoenix
Gesprächssendung die ist am Montag um
22:15 Uhr das ist der Tag der Deutschen
Einheit und Michaela Kolster wird sich
mit diesem Thema Tag der Deutschen
Einheit bei Unter den Linden
Beschäftigten Montag 22 Uhr 15
weiteres und aktuelles bei Phoenix der
Tag mit Michael krons darin geht es
unter anderem um die Einigung im
Bundeskabinett zum gaspreisdeckel
bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]